well hopefully winds didn't keep you up
last night they have been a little brisk
on the west side a couple of places like
boulder city and laughlin the sun is up
skies are clear and we'll have good air
quality for our last day of september
isn't that good news we've spent quite a
few days with smoky haze in our skies
with all those wildfires burning and
this past month as as well as back in
august but good air quality all the way
across the board today and temperatures
have been cooled off talk about ghoulish
a little spooky we've got temperatures
that have been even in the 50s
mountain's edge henderson you were at 59
just popped back up to 61. north breezes
are really starting to pick up now now
that we've got that sun up we're
expecting 20 25 mile an hour winds red
rock's got some breezes prompt you've
been in the low 50s same for indian
springs 53 in mesquite but because of
the breezes boulder city all the way
down the river and to lofland still
keeping it just a little above where we
expected to be this morning those north
winds have been around 20 25 miles an
hour consistently ealy at 20 degrees 40s
for caliani loughlin reno and up in
cedar city it is just chilled down it
feels like fall now so cool north breeze
is returning today and then 80s feeling
very mild all the way until we get into
the weekend we'll have a little bit of a
warm up again possible showers and
thunderstorms early next week and that
will get the roller coaster going you
know it's it's spring and fall we get
the roller coaster and we also get
showers and thunderstorms sometimes
tornadoes fall is the second tornado
season for the center part of the
country and over into the midwest
showers and thunderstorms could turn
severe for the gulf the mid-south and
the plains today and there could be some
flooding around albuquerque flood
watches have been posted all the way
into tomorrow we just got that cool
northerly flow that will keep things
extra fall like 62 up on the mountain
look for winds 25 miles an hour maybe
higher at times and the colors are all
beautiful up there the aspens have been
turning so nice 84 in the valley today
that's just two degrees warmer than
yesterday's 82 and we start october with
mid 80s again tomorrow a slow increase
in temperatures until we get to 90 91
sunday monday and then that chance of
thunderstorms on tuesday will bring
temperatures back down to the 80s next
week